also developing tonight the biden
administration continues to go soft on
china
despite increasing evidence supporting
the lab league theory that we warned
about the whole time
of the coronavirus origins when asked
yesterday if the bide administration
would seek to punish china for their
coveted cover-up
biden's principal deputy press secretary
replied quote
we're not going to go there just yet
but new house bills would launch a
coronavirus origins probe and allow
victims families to sue beijing
and that's not all because we're also
learning that the u.s reportedly has
unexamined intelligence on where exactly
the virus
started and get this former trump
official who was part of the former
secretary of state uh mike pompeo's
probe into the virus
he says the investigation found almost z
no evidence that's a big zero
supporting natural or avoiding the
natural origin uh
theory take a look well we were finding
that uh despite the claims of our
scientific community
uh including the national institutes of
health and dr fauci's
nyaid organization that there was almost
no
evidence that supported the natural
zoonotic
you know evolution the data
disproportionately
stacked up as we investigated that it
was coming out of
a lab or some supernatural source
but the biden team didn't even want to
entertain that theory and reportedly
actually shut the probe down in the
spring
so i don't want to hear any more
nonsense or talk from bone-headed libs
about so-called conspiracy theories ever
again from this point on thank you very
much
the media big tech they've all been
caught with their pants down again
censoring and trying to suppress
information that goes against
their political agenda joining me now
for reaction
former acting director of national
intelligence rick grinnell along with
republican congressman daryl isa
guys thank you so much um congressman
i'll go to you first
i mean this was obviously common sense
that the
lab leaked theory should at least be
analyzed we had a coronavirus pandemic
that originated in wuhan we had a
coronavirus lab in wuhan
that had been cited for security
problems in the past
i mean was it and by the way we found
out we had intelligence that
three workers in the lab got sick with a
coronavirus type illness
i mean was this not the most obvious
thing to look at and yet
we were called lunatics and conspiracy
theories for daring to bring it up
well you know dan my my late father
always said if someone looks guilty it
could be
because they're guilty when you have
those kinds of
of indications the important thing to do
is to follow the facts
and as you said the media has told us
not to follow the facts
the biden administration has denied them
but the the pressure is growing for a
real
commission you know we had we had we had
three thousand plus people die on nine
eleven and we kind of knew some of the
facts but we still had a commission that
that dealt deeply to make sure it didn't
happen again we now have 600 000 people
dead
trillions of dollars of damage to our
economy countless greater amounts to the
entire world
of course we have to look into it and we
have to look into all possibilities
and probabilities you know rick you've
been
an absolute warrior for the truth i i
follow you and i really enjoy
uh your social media reading and you you
have no problem going back and forth on
these media folks
and no i mean it and when are they gonna
get a story right
i mean we had the collusion hoax the
whole peepee tape thing
i mean are they ever gonna get a story
right they spent four years wasting our
time with bob mueller on that
we had this monstrous disgusting tragic
global pandemic wiped out economies and
lives
and they blow that story too is anybody
going to ever have faith in these guys
again
well i think outside of washington
nobody has face
has has faith in them they they look at
washington and they say
everything that goes on there they just
you know talk amongst themselves and
what newsrooms believe
is not what the american people believe
let let me just defend the intelligence
community here for a minute
from the very beginning if you go back
and you look at april 30th
2020 the statement from the intelligence
community
i see wide agreement was that
covet 19 started in china and that it
was either the wet market
or the lab and that we would begin to
look at information over time and we
would always bring forward information
the media and the democrats are the ones
who never
understood what the intelligence
community was saying
there is no evidence that is
unexamined the intelligence community
every single day
examines every piece that they have and
they bubble it up
if anyone is confused as to what the
evidence is showing
it's joe biden and the media the
evidence has been there i'd like to ask
why joe biden is suddenly asking for a
review
a 90-day review of the evidence that we
don't hold back evidence in the
intelligence community
if he hasn't seen evidence it's because
he's not being briefed and that's a real
problem
yeah that's an excellent point
congressman from your side on the house
side you know these three workers
employees in this wuhan coronavirus lab
where they were studying these bad
coronaviruses
they were sick with an illness there
were obviously blood samples taken
there had to be how can we as a
government
our government pressure them to release
those blood tests i mean once we get the
answer there i mean we should have a
pretty definitive answer
if there was an early infection from
that lab of these three lab employees
i think we can pretty much isolate the
lab leak theory and say that's the
likely one at this point
oh absolutely and that's the reason the
senate and i give them credit
unanimously voted to declassify this
information to begin to
to get it out there because it's the
only way to get out of this spin
and and i'm gonna i'm not a conspiracy
theorist but understand
the president united states is the
leader of the free world
but china is the leader of the unfree
world
they are using vast amounts of money and
influence including with the media
to stifle the kind of information that
rick saw when he was the director
that in fact we need to have the
american people understand
to get to the truth we're not going to
get to the truth as long as china
has influence over tech media and a
great many politicians
perhaps including the president yeah sad
but true
rick congressman thanks a lot enjoy your
weekend ahead thank you guys both
appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else